euh de l'exécutif quant à au déploiement
de la vaccination je constate c'est
qu'on est le 36e pays en matière de
vaccination
bon ça prouve à quel point on a un
système efficace
en normandie on aura deux usines qui
bientôt produiront des vaccins qui pour
l'un va être bientôt autorisés sur le
marché compte tenu de la faiblesse de la
vaccination
je vois pas comment dans quatre à six
semaines on pourrait se retrouver et
libérer
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 23 mars
la vaccination érigé en priorité
nationale par emmanuel macron mais quel
vaccin une agence américaine a mis en
doute aujourd'hui l'efficacité
revendiquée par astrazeneca pour son
sérum un nouveau coup dur qu'on le
laboratoire déjà sous pression en europe
quant à scouts nigré le vexin russe
utilisez déjà dans 56 pays efficace à
90% des états membres font pression pour
accélérer son approbation par l' agence
européenne du médicament
alors que moscou accuse bruxelles de
ralentir volontairement le processus
alors n'y at-il pas deux poids deux
mesures ce sera l'objet de notre
décryptage outre-rhin on semble revenu à
la case départ angela merkel parle d'une
nouvelle pandémie alors que le nombre de
contamination augmente la chancelière
prolonge les restrictions déjà en
vigueur mais le week-end de pâques et
mis sous cloche du 1er au 5 avril
allemagne sera pratiquement confiné
entre fermeture des commerçants et
annulations des offices religieux
zoom ce soir dans cette émission
également outre-atlantique au brésil
deuxième pays du monde le plus endeuillé
par la pandémie derrière les états unis
avec du 2 295 mille morts et rio de
janeiro particulièrement touchés a
annoncé un durcissement des restrictions
dix jours fériés décrétés durant
lesquelles seuls les commerces c'est
sensuel pour en ouvrir plus un couvre
feu entre 23h et 5h du matin
[Musique]
les dirigeants qui donne l'exemple pour
inciter à la vaccination et rassurer les
populations plusieurs l'ont déjà fait
joe biden aux états unis benyamin
nétanyahou en israël ou encore jean
castex en france ce soir c'était au tour
de vladimir poutine en russie de
recevoir sa première injection contre le
coc vide pour plus de précision on
retrouve en direct de moscou antoine l
claireaux bonsoir antoine aujourd'hui
c'est donc au tour du président russe de
montrer l'exemple mais loin des caméras
en revanche un oui tout à fait vladimir
poutine l'avait annoncé hier lors d'une
conférence en ligne avec les acteurs de
la vaccination
comme quoi il allait bien se faire
vacciner dans la journée d'aujourd'hui
son porte parole l'a confirmé il ya tout
juste quelques minutes
le président s'est fait vacciner et il
se sent bien at il également ajouté
par contre on ne saura pas quel vaccin a
été utilisé parmi les trois vaccins
développés en russie en effet en plus du
spoutnik v deux autres vaccins ont été
approuvés par les autorités russes
autre détail important vous l'avez
évoqué à la différence des responsables
politiques que vous avez cités ici pas
de mise en scène pas d'opération de
communication la scène de la vaccination
en elle-même n'a pas été filmée à une
vaccination antoine qui intervient dans
un contexte de tensions entre la russie
et l'union européenne
oui tout à fait un contexte
particulièrement tendu alors que le
vaccin russe spoutnik v est en train
d'être examinés par l' agence européenne
des médicaments
et c'est donc dans ce contexte que
thierry breton a déclaré dimanche soir
que l'union européenne n'avait pas
besoin du vaccin russe et ce alors que
sévit une pénurie de vaccins et des
retards de livraison par exemple de la
part d'astrazeneca
des propos qui ont étonné vladimir
poutine qui s'est posé la question de
savoir si le commissaire européen
défendez les intérêts de la population
ou bien ceux de l'industrie
pharmaceutique et antoine donc la
lumière coating qui sert d'exemple quant
à la vaccination
existe-t-il une
défiance en russie oui bien réussi la
problématique est la même qu'en france
il faut vacciner un maximum de monde
afin de développer une immunité
collective
il existe malgré tout des difficultés
supplémentaires déjà la défiance des
russes envers la vaccination en général
et puis également le fait qu'en russie
il n'y a pratiquement plus de
restrictions il n'y a donc pas cet
objectif de retour à la vie normale une
fois que suffisamment de monde sera
vacciné car le retour à la vie normale
on y est quasiment déjà merci antoine
gayraud en direct de moscou
d'un côté donc astrazeneca en difficulté
en europe mais aussi aux états unis
pourtant plébiscitée par bruxelles de
l'autre foot nick v utilisé dans 56 pays
efficace à 90% qui pourtant semble être
freinée par certains en europe alors y
at il deux poids deux mesures place à
notre décryptage avec nos invités
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
joëlle mélin un député européenne et
rennes ludovic toro mais rudy decae
ombrant bonsoir à tous les deux merci
d'être là je précise que vous êtes tous
les deux médecins six médecins m'ont dit
à chaque fois joëlle mélin mais on le
reste à vie comme je vous dis à chaque
fois merci en tout cas ludovic toro 1
qui semble-t-il serait en train de
vacciner à l'astra dans son cabinet
merci d'être avec nous en direct alors
un mot pour commencer justement sur ce
vaccin que vous utilisez ludovic toro
des nouveaux doutes des nouvelles
préoccupations tout cas autour de ce
sérum elles viennent des états unis
aujourd'hui où les autorités de santé
ont des doutes sur la fiabilité des
données qu'ils auraient étaient
obsolètes ça ne veut pas dire que le
vaccin n'est pas bon mais voilà il ya un
problème de confiance en tout cas tisser
rang d'entre eux le laboratoire
astrazeneca et les états unis
est ce que le régulateur américain a
raison de se méfier de ce vaccin
astrazeneca j'aurai le mélanger à 11
millions 11 millions d'anglais qui ont
été vaccinées il y en a 1 millions 4 en
france faut qu'on arrête de mettre des
doutes sur tous les vaccins quel que
soit le vaccin parce que simon sortira
jamais de cette pandémie
on sait très bien que le moyen de sortir
cette pandémie c'est la vaccination
alors on trouvera toujours des décos il
ya des effets secondaires des choses
comme ça mais c'est des cas qui auraient
eu lieu quand même c'est à dire que ça
existe des gens qui décèdent ça existait
les allergies ou cela mais aujourd'hui
il faut arrêter mais que haro sur les
vaccins nous avons les autorités
sanitaires pour l'europe on a là et même
de l'europe pour la france il a et même
de la france voilà point final
maintenant ce que disent les autres ils
peuvent le dire comme une folle nous on
est en france pour essayer de soigner
les gens mais bien au delà des prévenir
de ce fait peu vide mais dans le monde
c'est pareil donc ce qu'on arrive
vraiment parce que l'on a un travail
après très compliqué sur la vaccination
quand on reçoit les gens pour les
vacciner jacques c'était pas très facile
parce que astrazeneca a été mis en doute
au début mais maintenant avec les cas
qui arrive un peu de chaque pays surtout
des pays du nord c'est compliqué je
rappelle encore que et en ile de france
aujourd'hui mais la pandémie elle
explose on est à plus de 600 cas pour
100000 mois sur la scène et céline
département où j'exerce il y a urgence à
agir
et donc cette défiance par rapport
vaccin attendant c'est un tout petit peu
à m'énerver vue le jeudi de très peu
d'effets secondaires qu'on a pu noter on
comprend votre agacement lui de victor
ans mais à votre place mais enfin ce
n'est pas moins les médias qui jetons
cette suspicion l'avis de l'autorité et
surtout sur inoa victor o pardonnez moi
mais c'est la france qui a quand même
suspendu l'astra zeneca c'était
peut-être une faute hein alors attendez
on va être clair en fait ce qui s'est
passé c'est des pays nordiques et ont
tenu un moment l'allemagne l'italie
d'abord appuyer sur les boutons pour
cette une région après l'allemagne a
appuyé et la france est venu par la
suite parce qu'il faut les garder une
position européenne qui à mon avis n'est
pas aussi forte que ça ils vont le voir
puisque 13 clairement certains pays
aujourd'hui
signe des contrats il s'approche du
spoutnik il faut le dire il ya l'italie
il ya l'allemagne à l'espagne voilà ce
sont des faits aujourd'hui d'accord donc
non c'est pas vous dîtes pas que ces
journalistes mais je dirais glace ce
vaccin qu'on a le plus besoin c'est là
comment l'une des plus calmes et de gros
seins pour notre pays et on va s'en
passer aujourd'hui mais c'est pas
possible
ou alors si non excusez-moi mais en
termes d minutes et collective
on va même plus parler de 2021 on va se
projeter en 2022 dans cette joie demain
vous comprenez l'agacement du de victor
o alors c'est vrai que la france a
suspendu la strazeele et cas les
français étaient déjà pas vraiment
confiant il ya beaucoup de scepticisme
on le sait quant aux vaccins en france a
fait du mal à ce vaccin avec des
derniers développements avec les états
unis aujourd'hui ça n'arrange pas les
choses
évidemment non pas les choses c'est très
dommage puisque nous sommes c'est une
situation malheureusement je regarde à
la vaccination
il y a des études qui sont rien ne sort
pas il est urgent que le cdc
je plais ma puisse nous présenter des
études et vanille et une opposition
également deux natives avec ça aussi
adorent le bac ça astrazeneca n'est
probablement pas plus dangereux que sont
ordinairement échec ce qu'il revienne ne
sont pas beaucoup de problématiques
simplement rien
celui là est ce que sur les autres on ne
me rend ce qui est dommage c'est qu'il y
ait autour des contrats et je suis assez
bien placé pour savoir comment ça c'est
au tour des contrats et autour de
l'attitude de certains la bombe
un attentisme pour pouvoir lancer leur
chaîne de production cet attentisme
étant lié à des fous donné par l'union
européenne alors que d'autres
entreprises comme bien et est très
largement amant en ayant pris le soin de
s'appuyer sur une grande entreprise qui
était files air forcé beaucoup plus tôt
les chaînes de m'en direz des chaînes de
production
il n'en reste pas moins vrai que cela se
fait dans une chance et que dans aucun
cas les mains à ce jour ni les
organismes nationaux dont tous les
moyens pour juger précisément de la
fiabilité des mac ça c'est un vrai souci
mais c'est aussi l'invention à payer
pour voir sortir de cette épidémie alors
est donc exact oui raser les voir donner
un autre visage de lui il ya beaucoup
trop d'éléments autour de ce laboratoire
il est urgent de passer dans la
transparence en tout cas emmanuel macron
était à valenciennes aujourd'hui et il
annonce une accélération de la campagne
de vaccination c'est une priorité
nationale
on découvre cette voie la priorité
aujourd'hui semble-t-il ce dont doutent
d'ailleurs le leader de la france
insoumise
jean luc mélenchon écoutez si vous
voulez vacciner nuit et jour et le
maximum de monde il faut un maximum de
doses j'espère que tout le monde
comprend ce raisonnement parce que il
doit être tellement sophistiqués que
monsieur macro n'arrive pas à le
comprendre
donc il faut faire venir des vaccins 2
partout voilà une des réponses nous leur
avons dit qu' il fallait demander tous
les vaccins du monde n'est pas s'arrêter
à des préjugés idéologiques ou des
règlements de comptes entre pays
ça va même un peu loin pour certains
députés écoutez la réaction de gilles
lebreton au député européen et identité
et démocratie la commission de bruxelles
boycott le vaccin russe il est pourtant
plus fiable que l'astra zeneca dont le
manque de toute façon la hongrie la
tchéquie et la slovaquie l'on commande
est quand même et ont bien fait ludovic
toro vous y croyez justement à cette
notion de boycott du vaccin russe parce
que c'est vrai qu'on se pose la question
à regarder cette carte 1 y a pas que la
hongrie a un que cite monsieur lebreton
56 pays utilisent le spoutnik vais
pourtant il ya une forme voilà de
scepticisme et c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est un euphémisme quand on
entend thierry breton le commissaire
européen à leur boycott idéologique
thierry breton s'est trompé en
s'exprimant de la façon disons tout
allait bien on n'a pas besoin de vaccins
ce pique nique mais tout autre au vaccin
on a besoin de vaccin de tous les
vaccins mais sauf qui passe tout
simplement comme ils l'ont fait
d'ailleurs que je vous rappelle
cosmétiques et entrant l'avoir name aime
ou pas auprès de l'europe
donc ça c'est fait ça va être entérinée
très bientôt oui ou non mais tous les
patients ça va ça va être aussi simple
vous êtes confiant maintenant à donner
leurs aujourd'hui il ya quatre pays
conseiller un contrat avec les russes
d'accord par rapport à l'italie et à
l'espagne en allemagne ces trois pays
vont en effet vouloir la réponse aux
états et même européenne s'est de facto
ça pourra pas passer autrement on ne
peut pas maintenant peut-être qui
sortira avec un nom mais ils font foi
l'étudier du point de vue de la mma
priori les mêmes française et je vous
rappelle et la borne là et même
européenne
après la ligne française donc c'est tout
il ya même pas discuter ça soit le
spoutnik ou un autre ce sont des
médicaments pour essayer donc là en
l'occurrence des vaccins pour ressortir
cette pandémie
donc voilà ce qu'a dit je vous
conseillerais breton est un peu est
totalement exagéré on pas dire on n'a
pas besoin et surtout je vous rappelle
il a surtout dit que 14 juillet ça
serait terminée ce histoire ne sera 80%
d'immunité collective ce qui est
totalement impossible avoue vous citiez
l'allemagne en l2 victor on propose
d'écouter justement le député des
républicains ont des atouts maritimes
eric ciotti de la merkel
qu'en dit emmanuel macron arrêtons le
blocage politique du vaccin spoutnik v
ce relents de guerre froide alors que
près de cent mille français sont déjà
morts de coronavirus est indigne et
grave
joëlle mélin le fameux pragmatisme
allemand il faut suivre
effectivement l'allemagne désormais
manuel micro on doit arrêter ce qu'eric
ciotti qualifie de blocage politique
écoutez ce que je peux répondre malgré
tout on est d'ordinaire l'oma tu es beau
réaliste et le fait avec l'it et du
vaccin spoutnik en france et en europe
n'est pas comme me le rappelait mon
confrère les procédures sont simples il
ya eu c'est dur d'autorisation de mise
sur le marché par le roi et r'n'b et
adopte vaccins bien comprendre aussi
bien le cas de figure il tape pour les
laboratoires et les 25es produisions des
contrats avec la commission européenne
et qui eux ont d'emblée à peu près
concomitamment était autorisée par
l'union européenne chauffer à ce jour et
les autres vaccins sont produits en
dehors de ces cinq à six contrats qui
ont été signés par la commission
européenne
nous devons pouvoir faire appel à toutes
les doses des vaccins qui ont
contractualisé avec la commission
européenne
pouvoir avoir accès à la totalité des
autres laboratoires qu'ils soient
chinois qu'ils soient russes qu'il soit
pour d'autres d'amérique du sud certains
et qu'ils puissent dès l'instant qu'ils
sont reconnues comme fiables venir
compléter notre gamme pouvons plus
continuer comme ça parce que à force de
vernir ans était clair que quand on aura
fini ses vaccinations là surtout dans un
quart y ressemble à celui là quand on
aura fini couvrir certains du temps
peut-être pas d'autres
la faire à la fin d'un accident la
période de vaccination on va se
retrouver à devoir vacciner donc cela
est insupportable
il convient donc d'avoir des vaccins les
plus fiables et plus large possible pour
anticiper les mutations comme on le fait
tous les ans avec la grille des
alternatives à la vaccination ont
rassuré tout le monde
je la dois pouvoir se faire tout
particulièrement l'europe a mis sur la
table des fonds extrêmement important
c'est l'argent des contribuables des
contribuables doivent retrouver leur
argent sous forme de soins en tout cas
ces vaccins et notamment le vaccin à
russin est devenu l'objet de dissensions
entre la russie et l'union européenne je
vous propose d'écouter quand même
vadimir poutine un petit peu courroucé
on peut le comprendre peut-être après
les propos de thierry breton qui
soupçonne une lenteur un petit peu
volontaire le président russe nombreux
sont ceux qui ne savent pas ce qu il a
réussi a déposé il ya longtemps il me
demande d'enregistrement de son vaccin
auprès de l'alliance européenne des
médicaments
cela a été fait comme tatiana golikova
me l'a rapporté ce matin le 21 janvier
et ce n'est que le 4 mars que nous avons
été informés du fait que notre demande
commencer à être examinées 1 ludovic
toro il a raison quand même à venir
continuent de s'inquiéter de 2,7
lenteur européenne et on va essayer de
sauver la france l'europe et le monde
entier avec la vaccination
il est grand temps d'arrêter de se
battre et de s'affronter soit parce que
le vaccin via l'angleterre d'amérique de
russie d'accord on n'a pas pu le faire
en français on l'a reconnu pour
différentes raisons les salles après
lisa ultérieurement
aujourd'hui si un vaccin qui peut nous
aider à sentir que cette pandémie bien
sûr que vous le prendre je vous rappeler
quand même une étude sur le long cette
relance est ce un 2d journal de
référence pour nous car l'angleterre qui
a publié sur le spo cliquer sur les
phases 1 2 et 3 les épisodes pour
l'instant encourageant alors il faut
attendre et bien sûr là mêmes qui a été
déposé on verra bien ce que dit l'europe
mais déjà dire de la part de monsieur
breton j'en veux pas je comprends un peu
n'importe quel président d'un pays
auquel il aurait on reste ancré ça
surtout que là mêmes est en cours dire
qu'à une mêmes qui est en cours et on
dit qu'on n'aura pas besoin
et puis je vous rappelle quand même que
sa présidente ursula von dach hier a dit
qu'on aura besoin de tous qu'on s'est
trompé sur des commandes qu'on a été
trop naïf que ceux-ci que cela bon il
faudrait pas que ce commissaire
contredisent quand même sa présidente ça
serait quand même la moindre des choses
d'accord donc moi très clairement en
tant que médecin il me faut des vaccins
d'accord pour vacciner le plus possible
qu'ils viennent de n'importe où
franchement j'en ai rien à faire
pourquoi parce qu'il ya urgence vraiment
à traiter et à sony le pays est au coeur
du réacteur
puisque vous êtes députée européenne
clément bonin le secrétaire d'état
chargé des affaires européennes nous dit
le vaccin russe a déposé son dossier il
est examiné tout va bien deux à trois
mois au total on est dans cette phase
ce ne sera pas avant la fin mai début
juin
c'est normal c'est le rythme européen on
a bien vu que la commission européenne
quand elle a voulu lancer les travaux a
commencé à avoir des contacts dès le
mois de juillet avec différents
laboratoires
elle aurait parfaitement pu en avoir
aussi avec les laboratoires en
particulier la recherche publique un
petit peu plus en russie avec tous les
intervenants de tous les pays du monde
ils n'ont pas souhaité le faire je pense
que la commission européenne comme
accumulé énormément
retard au d'erreurs ou de véritable
contresens
il est urgent que tout le monde reprenne
raison et voit la situation comme elle
est nous avons à priori ce qui a l'air
de se dégager ce n'est pas une épidémie
avec des robots c'est plusieurs
épidémies avec les virus un peu plus
spécifique de chaque période qui a
expliqué que j'en avais pendant les
périodes chaudes les périodes froides
alors qu'on comprenait pas trop ce qui
se passait l'union européenne doit
impérativement se reprendre
la commission européenne doit se
reprendre et il faut que emmanuel macron
reprenne son indépendance on ne peut pas
vivre uniquement sous la tutelle de les
maquiller d'accord d'accord et qui donne
qui s'était à peine donné 48 heures pour
dire qu'un vaccin était mauvais un jour
me dont le lendemain nous sommes dans
des périodes très compliqué où il va
être éventuellement difficile de trouver
les responsabilités si nous avons face à
nous des aléas médicaux il faut que tout
le monde puisse être assurée il faut que
les états membres reprennent leur
liberté en matière de santé travaillent
ensemble soit en coordination en matière
de santé publique mais reprennent leur
semaine et les sanitaires
ludovic toro vous êtes d'accord la
france reprenne sa souveraineté comme à
d'ailleurs menacé de le faire engueuler
la marcal hier en allemagne
moi je suis vraiment un pro européen
mais d'ailleurs la présidente de la
commission brédy qui a eu des erreurs de
gestion des avoirs de commandes celle-là
reconnu d'accord mais pour l'instant
c'est vrai que moi ce que j'aurais
souhaité c'est que les ministres de la
santé de tous les pays européens sepa
fassent des contrôles puissent et puis
échanger entre eux on dirait que chaque
pays fait ce qu'il veut chaque pays
passe et comment y échapper applique des
restrictions différentes
il ya eu aucune homogénéité de tous les
pays
alors maintenant il ya eu les mêmes qui
va être demandé qu'à demander à l'europe
mais pourquoi pas lancer en même temps
une à et même sur la france le dire
puisque toute façon vous avez mis
lui-même européenne et même française
pourquoi attendre l'autorité européenne
alors qu'on a en france grandement ce
qu'il faut pour juger ou pas de ces
médicaments
on le fait tous les jours tous les jours
sans autorisation de l'europe
on valide des médicaments puisque notre
autonomie décisionnelle
pourquoi les mêmes n'a pas été lancée
aujourd'hui
pour la france sauf si la france d'ici
de ne pas prendre le spoutnik et voilà
mais je pense que je vous le dis juste
qu'il se passe en allemagne aujourd'hui
six alex s'accélère pas ils vont faire
une et même purement allemande y aura là
mêmes qui sera en espagne et mauritanie
et là encore ça qu'on ne fera pas
comment dire l'efficacité de notre
europe dans cette gestion de cette
pandémie
merci en tout cas à tous les deux les
deux vicaires euros joëlle mélin d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france ce
soir merci à vous deux et en france 9
vaccination érigé en priorité nationale
donc un par emmanuel macron le chef de
l'état qui était en déplacement ce matin
dans un centre de vaccination de
valenciennes dans le nord
le président qui prône une stratégie
ciblée sur des professions exposées pour
plus de précisions retrouvons tout de
suite et david khalifa en direct de
l'elysée bonsoir david priorité donc au
vaccin pour l'exécutif encore faut-il en
avoir suffisamment
oui au niveau des chiffres il ya de quoi
être pessimiste stéphanie à l'heure
actuelle environ 6 4 millions de
français ont reçu une première dose près
de 2,5 millions de personnes ont reçu la
deuxième bien loin des objectifs
annoncés par l'exécutif est pourtant le
président 1 se veut confiant vacciner
massivement c'est l'objectif affiché est
d'emmanuel macron le mois prochain la
france devrait franchir un cap
écoutez porto à partir de mi fin avril
nous allons avoir de plus en plus de
vaccins qui vont arriver et on sera à ce
moment là dans une situation qui nous
permettra en effet d'envisager d'avoir
des campagnes ciblées sur des
professions qui sont exposés à qui on
demande des efforts les enseignants font
légitimement partir à partir de ce
samedi
nous avons décidé d'ouvrir à la
vaccination pour les plus de 70 ans dans
les centres de vaccination avec le
kaiser et le moderne maintenant le coeur
de la bataille sur les prochaines
semaines et les prochains mois ce sera
la vaccination
matin midi et soir je peux vous dire je
serai mobiliser le gouvernement sera
mobilisé les déclarations pleines
d'optimisme qui contraste avec un retard
toujours plus conséquent dans le
planning de vaccination un responsable à
cette campagne ratée l'union européenne
en négociant au nom des 27 la commission
européenne a certes pu payer ces vaccins
pl1 moins cher au prix est d'une lenteur
plus important que la commission ne
prenant aucune décision est sans
l'accord des 27 pays membres sur le
choix
un des vaccins l'imbroglio astrazeneca
dont les taux d'utilisation sont un très
loin et de ceux de pfizer et un modern
art est également responsable elle de ce
retard les doutes autour de son
efficacité et la suspension de la
campagne après un des cas de thrombose
font qu'aujourd'hui des centaines de
milliers de doses dorment toujours dans
des frigos à david en parallèle
la situation sanitaire est de plus en
plus inquiétant entre en france
[Musique]
c'est le cas de le dire la pression
hospitalière notamment en ile de france
explose tout juste reconfirmer le taux
d'incidence est de 549 cas pour 100000
habitants contre 350 il ya là deux
semaines conséquence directe de niveau à
des formes graves 1325 malades elles
sont hospitalisées dans des unités de
soins critiques et de la région c'est
plus que lors du pic de la deuxième
vague
à titre d'exemple les soignants tire
donc la sonnette d'alarmé sur les
capacités d'accueil elles des patients
qu'aux vide en réanimation le point de
rupture est presque atteint selon le
mode et responsable ap hp et et les
mesures prises par les et cultive
n'auront pas eu d'impact non plus selon
eux en france 1 4634 patients sont
actuellement en réanimation ce qui
représente 1 488 admission 24 heures des
chiffres un plus qu'alarmant qui est
devrait forcer l'exécutif à prendre à d'
autres mesures encore plus drastiques
dans les régions concernées notamment la
fermeture des écoles mais pour l'instant
ce n'est qu'une hypothèse
merci david kelly fait en direct de
l'elysée restez avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de l'allemagne
angela merkel parle d'une nouvelle
pandémie alors que le nom de
contamination augmente chancelière aux
longues les restrictions déjà en vigueur
mais le week-end de pâques est lui mis
sous cloche direction rio de janeiro au
brésil
la ville a annoncé un durcissement là
encore des restrictions dix jours fériés
décrétés durant lesquelles celle des
commerces essentiel pourront ouvrir
[Musique]
oui
gilet jaune au début ce n'était pas un
mouvement politique le peuple français
était arrivé au bout de ce qu'il pouvait
supporter il ya énormément de problèmes
en france comment se fait-il qu'on est
les impôts les plus élevés d'europe
comment se fait-il qu'on est les
déficits les plus importants
et comment se fait-il que nous dans les
campagnes on n'est même plus de service
public quand je vois l'état du pays
aujourd'hui
honnêtement j'ai mal au coeur c'est
justement tout le sens de la prochaine
élection présidentielle parce que c'est
là qu'il va falloir que les gens
apportent des réponses et moi je crois
que de toute façon on ne peut pas régler
les problèmes avec ceux qui les ont
créés et c'est impossible
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
sable est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autorités assez
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous le numéro i l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inouï pg les gens ne s'étaient des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l oblique
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il ya quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
[Musique]
comment l'économie chinoise at elle
résisté à la pandémie de coronavirus l'
empire du milieu est il le grand gagnant
de cette crise la chine est encore
lucide du monde luc ses clients sont en
récession tous les produits chinois ne
sont pas vendus la consommation les
sikhs en chine depuis la crise et la
relance de 2007-2008 a pris le pas sur
les autres facteurs de croissance que la
chine soit la première à repartir c'est
une certitude c'est les premiers à avoir
maîtrisé la pandémie ils ont préféré
mettre le paquet sur la règle de la du
virus et ont retrouvé des conditions
normales d'activité économique plutôt
que sur des relances monétaire ou de
l'endettement de l'état
l'espèce de jeu pouvoir pour la
suprématie mondiale la chine à quelques
mètres d'avancé sur ses poursuivants
[Musique]
20h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez la
pandémie toujours et la troisième vague
outre-rhin les contraintes vont se
durcir à la proche des fêtes de pâques
les précisions de peter oliver notre
correspondant à berlin
laissez moi un nouveau confinement que
la continuation du confinement mis en
place en allemagne en novembre
cependant y avoir des restrictions
supplémentaires pour pâques
cela a choqué beaucoup de gens car on
s'attendait à des assouplissements pour
cette période à une v2 rester sur les
chiffres de la colline suggère que cela
ne serait pas du tout à viser les
opinions sont partagées quant à la
pertinence de cette continuation du
conseil docteur les professionnels de
santé pointe du doigt ces chiffres et 10
c'est un répit pour nous car les
hôpitaux frôle leur pleine capacité
l'osce m maxime scandale généreuse
matches et beaucoup se sont pris de
vapeur tombe en pâmoison face à cette
décision qu angela merkel et les
dirigeants des sept états allemands ont
pris lundi
plus tôt mardi matin après 15 heures
d'âpres négociations un accord selon
l'analyste entré dans une nouvelle
guerre des miss
car le nombre de cas de kovy de grimper
depuis environ une semaine 6 1 lundi sur
sept jours et en ce moment à 108% mille
c'est à dire que 108 personnes sont
testés positifs sur 100 m cela dans ce
texte le frein d'urgence conçu va tout
arrêter si la situation dégénère était
supposé être activé à 104% mon père
ce qui est largement dépassée par les
médias sans toutefois scandalisé et
disent que le gouvernement veut
détourner l'attention du c'est
maintenant notamment concernant les
vaccins sont mécontents de mesures
décidées mardi me demanderez-vous les
équipes devront tenir leurs services en
ligne sa cas d'une seulement de deux
foyers maximum pour ce 3 avril et c'est
sans doute ce qui passe le moins sera le
seul jour sur les sacs de la période
pascale ou les supermarchés pour ouvrir
open cela suscite beaucoup de colère car
les commerces sont pratiquement
complètement à l'arrêt suite à cette
région dans gala merkel et des
représentants des seize seront requis
pour toute personne rentre en allemagne
après les vacances à l'étranger
il ya encore très peu de temps même si
beaucoup de choses ont changé dans
l'intervalle l'allemagne avait indiqué
que majorque était une destination
acceptable et beaucoup de personnes
avaient déjà pris des réservations ils
vont peut-être y repensez à deux fois
à propos d'astrazeneca
angela merkel a déclaré suite à sa
réunion avec les dirigeants locaux
qu'elle soutenait sur ce la vente vers
l'ailleurs la président de la commission
m
et qu'il y avait selon ses propres
termes un problème avec cela band
airlines a menacé ce week end et bloqué
les exportations du vaccin
astrazeneca les doses produites sur les
territoires européens pourraient être
interdits d'exportation hors du bloc
jusqu à ce qu astrazeneca est tenu ses
engagements avec l'union
honorer votre contrat avec lieu d'abord
c'est le message ursula von der leyen
qui sera répétée lors d'un sommet
européen crucial ce jeudi s'il faut
mettre à exécution la menace d'empêcher
les exportations de vaccins notamment
vers le royaume uni avec les
conséquences que cela pourrait avoir sur
l'avenir des relations entre les lieux
et le royaume uni m eur cours directrice
de l'agencé européenne du médicament a
annoncé jeudi que les centres de
production du vaccin sont vus en russie
serait contrôlé par des agents de la m
elle n'a pas donné de date mais cela
intervient peu de temps après la
déclaration de thierry breton chef du
moins le travail sur la production de
vaccins de la commission européenne
enverra des vaccins selon lequel
l'europe n'a pas besoin du scout 9eme
sponeck vkp à pour certains le sujet est
politisée il semble effectivement que
cela soit au moins en partie le cas mais
la réalité du terrain et qu'il n'y a pas
assez de vaccins en europe en ce moment
plusieurs états membres ont déjà acheté
des doses de ce sommet lui-même certains
états membres ne dispenserait même déjà
mais on a échoué en bas et d'allemagne
angela merkel a affirmé que seraient
disposés à acheter des douze de spots
nick v mais attendent l'autorisation de
la haie mais à défaut d'autorisation at
elle également dit l'allemagne pourrait
avancer dernier on a évoqué des
investissements dans une usine de bade
wurtemberg qui pourrait bien produire le
studio en allemagne sur le territoire
européen
cela facilite
la distribution auprès d'une population
très demandeuse de vaccination le plan
qui ne changent pas en allemagne et
d'offrir à tous ceux qui le souhaitent
la vaccination d'ici septembre
cela semble extrêmement ambitieux à ce
jour mais je le répète c'est le blanc et
outre manche à 12h précises heure locale
londres s'est figé une minute de silence
à winchester le parlement devant les
hôpitaux et ailleurs pour rendre hommage
aux 126 mille morts de la pandémie de
coronavirus un nouveau au jour après la
mise en place du premier confinement au
royaume-uni pays européen le plus
endeuillé par le cos vide et la médiane
26 millions de britanniques ont reçu
leurs premières doses antico vide soit
un adulte sur deux au royaume uni
londres promet d'offrir une injection à
toute la population majeure du pays
d'ici fin juillet le premier ministre
britannique s'est lui-même mise en scène
pour défendre le vaccin d'oxford
astrazeneca vendredi 19 mars
boris johnson a reçu sa première
injection de ce sérum développer sur le
sol anglais une façon de rassurer après
les suspensions en cascade par
précaution de ce vaccin dans plusieurs
pays européens
clairement ce qui nous importe au
royaume uni c'est de poursuivre le
déploiement du programme de vaccination
je pense que nous avons maintenant
vaccinée plus de la moitié des adultes
dans le pays ceux qui ont créé très
bonne nouvelle sur le continent mais
malheureusement constaté qu'une
troisième vague est en cours et les
habitants de ce pays ne doivent pas se
faire d'illusions l'expérience nous a
appris que lorsqu'une vague frappe nos
amis elles s'échouent également sur le
coach et je m'attends à ce que nous
ressentions ses effets en temps voulu
c'est pourquoi nous poursuivons notre
programme de vaccination aussi vite que
possible
londres a lancé sa campagne de
vaccination dès le 8 décembre dernier
le royaume uni a été le tout premier
pays au monde à donner son feu vert au
vaccin des laboratoires pfizer bio ntech
puis d'astrazeneca un contrôle de la
pandémie qui tranche avec l'inquiétante
situation que connaissait le pays
il y à renens le premier ministre
britannique avait d'ailleurs été
largement critiquée pour sa gestion au
début de la crise sanitaire
selon son entourage boris johnson a
nommé aujourd'hui avoir pris trop
tardivement les premières mesures de
confinement après avoir opté pour des
règles souples le royaume uni rattrapé
par la pandémie s'était finalement
résolu à changer de stratégie
boris johnson lui-même avait été atteint
par le corona virus il ya aussi
quasiment un an mais de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique à présent au brésil un
durcissement des restrictions contre le
coc u19 a été annoncé dans deux villes
dont rio une annonce qui intervient
alors que les querelles politiques font
rage dans le pays entre les gouverneurs
les maires et le président bolle sudaro
sur la conduite à tenir face à la
pandémie dans ce pays le plus touché par
la pandémie après les états unis dans la
ville de rio et sa voisine niteroi
on ne parle pas de confinement mais de
jean ferrier
ce lundi de nouvelles restrictions
étaient annoncés par leur mère du 26
mars au 4 avril
seuls les commerces essentiel pourront
ouvrir un couvre-feu entrera en vigueur
de 23h à 5h et les restaurants ne
pourront pratiquer que la vente à
emporter
aucun d'entre nous ne prend ses
décisions aujourd'hui de manière
heureuse joyeuse ou par plaisir
nous prenons ces décisions par nécessité
absolue et en écoutant la science en
comprenant les aspects sociaux et
économiques
mais en écoutant vraiment la science
vendredi dernier déjà le maire de rio
avait décidé de fermer les plages pour
le week-end une mesure comprises par ses
administrés je suis né et j'ai grandi
ici et je n'ai jamais vu la plage vide
comme ça néanmoins il s'agit d'une
mesure importante pour éviter
l'entassement ici sur la promenade les
gens marchent mais à distance et c'est
essentiel pour contenir le variant
brésilien qui est terrible et je vois
cela comme une mesure importante parce
que les gens ne respectaient pas les
gestes barrière est de sorte que l'état
a dû intervenir parce que sinon les cap
de caux vide ne ferait qu'augmenter et
les gens continueraient à mourir c'est
une situation très compliquée à laquelle
nous sommes confrontés au brésil
principalement ici à rio par le taux
d'occupation des services de soins
intensifs
il dépasse les 90% les maires de ces
deux vies
on voulait aller plus loin mais le
gouverneur de l'état de rio un fidèle
allié de géants wolson araud a refusé
l'instauration de mesures plus
restrictives
et pourtant il dirige l'état le plus
affecté du pays avec plus de 35 mille
décès sur fond de crise sanitaire dans
le deuxième pays le plus endeuillé au
monde se déploient les querelles
politiques entre les maires et les
gouverneurs et les gouverneurs et le
président c'est à sao paulo où les rues
sont quasi désertée depuis la mise en
place le 15 mars de mesures restrictives
que se trouve le plus farouche opposant
à la politique menée par le président
nous traversons une de ces tragiques
période de l'histoire au cours
desquelles des millions de personnes et
le prix d'avoir un dirigeant psychopathe
et manquant de préparation à la tête de
la nation signe d'une gestion chaotique
de la crise au plus haut sommet de
l'état
en un an 4 ministre de la santé se sont
succédé plus de 290000 personnes sont
mortes ducobu et pour en parler nous
sommes avec hervé théry géographe
professeur à l'université de sao paulo
bon soit avec ali merci d'être avec nous
on vient totalement les chiffres
inquiétants 35 mille décès dans l'état
de rio 90 % d'occupation des lits de
réanimation les choses sont loin de
s'arranger bien au contraire ce qu'on
peut craindre clairement l'effondrement
du système de santé
il en est tout près le système public
est en très mauvais état de toujours été
très négligée et le plus le système
privé commence aussi à donner vraiment
des signes de fatigue
ce n'est pas étonnant le set 7 la
gestion de la crise était calamiteuse
depuis le début de votre sujet vient de
le rappeler il ya tout le monde tire à
hue et à dia et les mesures qui viennent
d'être prises pour dix jours
son appel semblable à celle qu'on a
prises en france l'an dernier pendant 55
jours
donc c'est bien tu avais bien peu il
tant de villes alors au coeur de sa
tranche évidemment une intense guerre
politique qui fait rage entre eux mêmes
un gouverneur mais aussi entre les
gouverneurs et président bolle sonar au
ces ce qui complique la lutte contre le
coc vide dès le départ d'ailleurs c'est
principalement effective ou autre l'état
fédéral dirigé par jacques sonar il est
gouverneur les gouverneurs entre eux ont
pas tellement de raison de se disputer
ils ont vraiment tous à faire avec le
gouvernement fédéral avec des options
différentes mais par exemple
l'association nationale des secrétaires
de santé ou des ministres de la santé
des différents états travaillent de
façon unie et essaie de coordonner leurs
actions sans l'action de l'état fédéral
mais parfois contre l'état fédéral
donc il ya beaucoup plus de bonne
volonté auprès du terrain dans les
communes il a un des maires dans lego
dans les états par les gouverneurs
malgré et contre l'état fédéral qui
donne des signes évidents de gotein
qu'il n'y ait pas d'autres mots de
négligence ou de cinq otages de la
campagne
alors effectivement quand le maire de
rio a décrété dix prochains jours fériés
et a fermé donc les plages et les
commerces de proximité tout en
instaurant prochains jours fériés max
hoarau lui a répondu que finalement
privée je cite les brésiliens de soleil
et de vitamine d bien ça augmenterait
les risques d'attraper les locaux vides
c'est quoi c'est le déni de la
provocation ou peut-être on a du mal à
savoir s'il est idiot s'il fait son nom
est idiot si c'est un calcul malin en
pensant uniquement à son élection
mais je pourrais vous faire une longue
collection de ces déclarations de des
plus stupéfiante ce consistait à dire
que si les gens se vacciner les femmes
deviendraient des hommes et les hommes
deviendraient des crocodiles quand on en
est à ce point là il n'y a plus qu'à
tirer les cheveux il ya quelques jours
il encore dit brettés de vous plaindre
arrêté de geindre continuer c'est pas
grave la vaccination a du mal comme en
france à
il ya beaucoup de retard elle a commencé
à la mi janvier seuls 6% des brésiliens
ont reçu une première dose du vaccin
pourquoi autant de retard également au
brésil mais parce que ça ne peut être
localisé pendant longtemps le président
va les ministres de la santé successifs
les virer les uns après les autres leur
ont dit que c'était pas la peine que le
vaccin n'était pas très utile se sont
abstenus d'en acheter donc y en a pas en
france on a des problèmes et je si j'ai
bien compris en avril il va arriver
quelques millions de doses donc c'est
plutôt une question de retard tandis
qu'au brésil rien et annoncés et ceux
qui sont fabriqués au brésil quand ça va
à peu près mais les autres comme les
autorités brésiliennes se sont présentés
pour acheter des vaccins
après tout le monde il y en aura pas
pour tout le monde tant s'en faut et il
manque de l'oxygène et il manque des
lits manquent de tout ce que vous
écrivez c'est quasiment une assistance à
personne en danger ce que la population
brésilienne en veut à son président il
ya une partie c'était un peu comme le
soutien de trump ya 20 30 % qui le
suivent quoi qu'il dise quoi qu'il fasse
avec des tas de fête niveau ce qui
circule plusieurs tubes les unes que les
autres mais comme ils vivent en circuit
fermé et il se hisse au taux est toxique
la cote de popularité de jabot sonore
s'effondre constamment en particulier
depuis que le trump a été battue je
crois que vraiment le le miroir s'est
fêlé à ce moment là et donc là ils sont
en train d'essayer de remettre secours
d'urgence essayer de rattraper un peu
mais pour l'instant il est en train de
dévisser le fait que maintenant le enfin
un opposant crédible c'est à dire que le
président lula
l'ex-président lula va sans doute
pouvoir se présenter et donc
l'opposition qui n'avait aucun
championnat maintenant donc ça aide
aussi le choco et de lula est ce que ça
peut obliger balso narrow à changer sa
stratégie face au co vide
il a déjà commencé depuis quelques jours
il dit que le vaccin c'est très bien
qu'il faut sauver accéder je pense qu'il
est en train de lancer une offensive un
peu de de charme mais lula a commencé un
petit peu avant lui est donc sauf
imprévu parce que la justice brésilienne
est très imprévisible
on s'achemine vers le match entre 2 et
une opposition entre eux
et d'après les sondages de l'aed
largement en tête dernière question sur
le vaccin on parle beaucoup des
différents vaccins en europe quels sont
les vaccins disponibles qui disait au
brésil le plus disponible c'est une
coopération avec la chine qui donne qui
on voit les principes actifs et le reste
est fabriqué sur place il ya très très
bonne institut équivalent de pasteur
mais qui est une très bonne réputation
qui fait beaucoup de choses qui est qui
a commencé un produit et il a une très
belle expérience comme quand il ya eu la
la la grippe n1h1 ils ont vacciné 80
millions de personnes trois semaines
donc c'est pas qu'il ya pas de savoir
faire il ya du savoir-faire pour
fabriquer des vaccins et les distribuer
il a vraiment fallu le mettre beaucoup
d'énergie pour saboter la campagne qu'on
soit ou non merci avery géographe et
professeur à l'université de sao paulo
nous avoir expliqué la situation au
brésil mercia bout je vous prie c'est
dans le reste de l'actualité pékin
visait justement par des sanctions
américaines et européennes dans le
dossier des ouigours dans ce bras de fer
diplomatique l'ambassadeur de chine en
france a été convoqué ce matin par le
quai d'orsay pour des propos jugés
insultants convocation également tout à
l'heure des représentants chinois en
belgique et en allemagne est d'admettre
que les loups shy ambassadeur de chine
en france est convoqué ce mardi au quai
d'orsay une injonction au terme d'une
journée de frictions entre pékin et les
pays occidentaux sur le dossier épineux
des ouigours l'union européenne le
canada le royaume uni ainsi que les
états unis ont adopté ce lundi des
sanctions contre différents dirigeants
chinois du xinjiang la province du nord
ouest de la chine en majorité peuplée
par cette minorité musulmane en
représailles pékin s'en prend à dix
responsables européens parmi lesquels
l'eurodéputé raphaël glucksmann l'union
européenne a imposé des sanctions
unilatérales contre des personnes et
entités chinoises le 22 mars invoquant
la soi-disant problématique des droits
de l'homme au xinjiang
cette décision basée sur rien d'autre
que des mensonges et de
des informations ne tient pas compte et
déforment les faits et interfère
grossièrement dans les affaires
intérieures de la chine
la partie chinoise décide de sanctionner
ces dix personnes et quatre entités de
l'union européenne qui portent gravement
atteinte à la souveraineté et aux
intérêts de la chine et répondent de
manière malveillante des mensonges et de
la désinformation entre la france et la
chine
la confrontation diplomatique est montée
d'un cran dès vendredi
en cause des propos jugés inadmissibles
tenus la veille par l'ambassadeur à
l'égard d'un chercheur français jugé
trop critique envers pékin sur le
dossier taïwanais face à ces insultes
des experts en géopolitique ainsi que
des parlementaires ont pris la défense
du chercheur amenant le ministre
français des affaires étrangères à
réagir
toujours sur twitter dans nos relations
avec la chine
il n'y a pas de place pour les insultes
et les tentatives d'intimidation contre
les élus de la république et des
chercheurs
nous défendons ceux qui incarnent la
liberté d'expression et la démocratie
toujours et partout
l'ambassade de chine en france est
coutumière de ces piques à l'encontre
des détracteurs de pékin louchats y
avait déjà été convoqué par le ministère
des affaires étrangères en avril 2020
après des écrits jugés déplacés
le message de la chaîne en france
désormais éclair l'époque où la chine
encaissait sans riposter est bel et bien
révolue
aux etats unis une nouvelle fusillade
relance le débat sur le contrôle des
armes à feu
hier un homme de 21 ans a abattu dix
personnes dont un policier dans un
supermarché au colorado
une nouvelle tuerie de masse moins d'une
semaine après celle intervenue atlanta
dans l'état de géorgie où huit personnes
avaient trouvé la mort majoritaires à la
chambre des représentants et au sénat
les démocrates souhaitent renforcer la
législation sur les armes une volonté
également partagé par le président mbaye
dème nous pouvons combler les lacunes de
notre système de vérification des
antécédents notamment la faille de
charleston c'est l'un des meilleurs
outils dont nous disposons actuellement
pour prévenir la violence par armes à
feu
le sénat devrait immédiatement adopté je
le répète le sénat américain j'espère
que certains nous écoutent devrait
immédiatement adopté les deux projets de
loi adopté par la chambre qui comble les
lacunes du système de vérification des
antécédents
ce n'est pas ce ne devrait pas être une
question partisane c'est une question
américaine cela va sauver des vies des
vies américaines et nous devons agir
nous devrions également interdire les
fusils d'assaut dans la foulée une
modification de la législation par arme
à feu qui semble très compliqué les
démocrates ayant besoin d'au moins 60
voix au sénat pour modifier la loi sur
les armes à feu cela fait plus de trois
décennies que le congrès n'a pas réussi
à faire adopter une nouvelle législation
dans le pays les républicains ont de
nouveau réaffirmé leur opposition à
toute modification deuxième amendement
de la constitution
comme beaucoup d'américains the cherry
mon droit de porter des armes dans le
dialogue sur le contrôle des armes à feu
nous considérons rarement combien les
américains sont unis dans leur défense
et leur jouissance de ce droit à chaque
fois qu'ils viennent fusillade
on joue cette ridicule et pièces de
théâtre ou ce comité se réunit et
propose un tas de lois qu'il ne ferait
rien pour arrêter ces meurtres restent
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de la nouvelle doctrine du
gouvernement face au co vide vacciner
tous les jours matin midi et soir comme
l'a dit ce matin
macron lors d'un déplacement dans le
nord et puis nous reviendrons sur cette
stratégie le gouvernement at il encore
vraiment le contrôle sur l'épidémie et
sur la tenue des élections
départementales et régionales à la merci
d'un nouveau report
[Musique]
ce sont les trafics de drogue d'une
certaine façon qui sont peut-être les
meilleurs adeptes de la mondialisation
c'est à dire que ils ont inventé les
routes de la drogue bien avant que les
entreprises ne découvrent les bienfaits
de la mondialisation on ne visualise pas
à quel point ça peut être compliqué de
se retrouver avec dans son garage une
montagne de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose l'argent
sale devient très rapidement et très
facilement gris et puis blanc il suffit
de passer par quelques sociétés écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dit aux nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
le maniement de la rumeur est vieux
comme le monde mais il est vrai que
l'arrivée des réseaux sociaux il va
donner une crédibilité destructrices
dans sa virtualité l'impôt nuance a pris
toute sa place au coeur des
affrontements politiques et économiques
internationaux car elle est une
manifestation de la puissance capable de
peser sur l'évolution des situations
tous les jours nous entendons des
accusations de complotisme contre ceux
qui n'adhèrent pas à la pensée qu'on
dans le fond la théorie du complot
l'explication la plus simple et la plus
facile d'autant qu'elle permet de
désigner un bouc émissaire
évidemment coupable du pire vouloir
forcer le destin en récrivant une
histoire biaisée pour servir ses
intérêts ne tient pas dans la durée car
la vérité finit toujours par éclater
[Musique]
comment l'économie chinoise at elle
résisté à la pandémie de coronavirus l'
empire du milieu est il le grand gagnant
de cette crise la chine est encore
lucide du monde luc ses clients sont en
récession tous les produits chinois ne
sont pas vendus la consommation les
sikhs en chine depuis la crise et la
violence de 2007-2008 a pris le pas sur
les autres facteurs que prince pense que
la chine soit la première à repartir
c'est une certitude c'est les premiers à
avoir maîtrisé la pandémie ils ont
préféré mettre le paquet sur l'arrêt de
bus venus et ont retrouvé des conditions
normales d'activité économique plutôt
que sur des relances monétaire ou de
l'endettement des pages l'espèce de jeu
pouvoir pour la suprématie mondiale la
chine à quelques mètres d'avancé sur ses
poursuivants
[Musique]
exempté
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
nous sommes une équipe
[Musique]
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
louis saillant est un mec ce commando
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme à au
sahel l'ennemi la barre est parfaitement
légitime qu'on parle de jay liste on
parle de gens qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême serre est un terreau qui peut
favoriser l'extension du terrorisme ne
faut pas imaginer qu'il suffit
simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre pour
que l'islam c'est à dire là qui sont
embrigadés ils ont été séduits ils ont
été manipulés et d'autres qui agissent
de manière parfaitement consciente et
lucide je respecterai toujours
l'adversaire même si je méprise
totalement son idéologie comme c'est le
cas pour sega liste
[Musique]
21h merci de rejoindre pensait deuxième
heure d'émission tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce mardi 23
mars
emmanuel macron veut accélérer la
campagne vaccinale en france le
président qui prône une stratégie ciblée
sur les professions exposées les
enseignants devraient être vaccinés à la
mi-avril après avoir écarté les
vaccinodromes le gouvernement annonce
l'ouverture d'au moins 30 min 35 grand
centre dans l'espoir de vacciner 30
millions de personnes d'ici à l'été un
revirement critiqué par l'opposition
la stratégie d' emmanuel macron pour
faire face à la crise sanitaire mise à
mal face à la propagation du variant
britannique et par les retards de
livraison du vaccin l'exécutif est il en
train de perdre le contrôle de
l'épidémie d'une autre échéant cette
fois-ci électorale avec les régionales
ce sera l'objet de l'édito d'alexis
poule à
[Musique]
toujours en france polémique à
strasbourg en alsace la majorité
municipale europe ecologie les verts de
la ville a adopté ce lundi le principe
d'une subvention de plus de deux
millions et demi d'euros pour la
construction d'une mosquée un projet
chapeauté par l'association milli gorus
réputé proche de la turquie est critiqué
par le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin en israël 6 millions 500 mille
personnes appelées aux urnes aujourd'hui
pour les quatrièmes législatives en
moins de deux ans l'actuel premier
ministre a émis netanyahou au pouvoir
depuis 12 euros est donné favori en
toile de fond l'intense campagne de
vaccination anti kobe des le feuilleton
juridique qui vise le chef du likoud
accusé de corruption
[Musique]
la vaccination érigé en priorité
nationale par emmanuel macron le chef de
l'état qui était en déplacement ce matin
dans un centre de vaccination de
valenciennes dans le nord le chef de
l'état qui prône une stratégie ciblée
sur des professions exposées les
précisions de david kelly fin au regard
des chiffres il ya de quoi être plus que
pessimiste à l'heure actuelle environ 1
6 4 millions de français ont reçu une
première dose à près de 2,5 millions de
personnes ont reçu la deuxième bien loin
des objectifs annoncés par l'exécutif
pourtant le président se veut confiant
vacciner massivement c'est l'objectif
annoncé des manuels macron le mois
prochain la france devrait franchir un
nouveau cap écouter surtout à partir de
mi fin avril nous allons avoir de plus
en plus de vaccins qui vont arriver et
on sera à ce moment là dans une
situation qui nous permettra en effet
d'envisager d'avoir des campagnes
ciblées sur des professions qui sont
exposés à qui on demande des efforts
les enseignants font légitimement partir
à partir de ce samedi
nous avons décidé d'ouvrir à la
vaccination pour les plus de 70 ans dans
les centres de vaccination avec le
kaiser et le moderne maintenant le coeur
de la bataille sur les prochaines
semaines et les prochains mois ce sera
la vaccination
matin midi et soir je peux vous dire je
serai mobiliser le gouvernement sera
mobilisé dès la déclaration pleine
d'optimisme qui contraste avec un retard
toujours plus conséquent dans le
planning de vaccination un responsable à
cette campagne ratée l'union européenne
en négociant au nom des 27 la commission
européenne a certes plus à payer ses
vaccins moins cher au prix d'une lenteur
un plus importante la commission ne
prenant aucune décision sur l'accord des
27 pays membres sur le choix
les vaccins l'imbroglio d'astrazeneca
dont les taux d'utilisation
a sion sont très loin de ceux de pfizer
et un modern art est également
responsable de ce retard les doutes
autour de son efficacité et la
suspension après des cas de thrombose
info qu' aujourd'hui des centaines de
milliers de doses à dorment toujours
dans les frigos
en parallèle en france la situation à
sanitaire est de plus en plus
inquiétante la pression hospitalière
notamment en ile de france explose tout
juste confiner le taux d'incidence est
de 549 cas pour 100000 habitants contre
1 350 il y a deux semaines elle
conséquence directe au niveau à des
formes graves 1325 un malades sont
hospitalisés dans les unités à de soins
un critique de la région elle c'est plus
que lors du pic de la seconde vague à
titre d'exemple les soignants tire donc
la sonnette d alarme sur les capacités à
d'accueil des patients qu'aux vide en
réanimation
le point de rupture est presque atteint
selon les responsables de l'ap-hp les
mesures prises par l'exécutif ne
suffiront pas à atténuer l'épidémie en
france est 4634 patients sont
actuellement en réanimation ce qui
représente 1 488 admission en 24 heures
des chiffres là plus qu'alarmant qui a
devrait forcer à l'exécutif à prendre
des mesures encore plus drastiques dans
les régions concernées a notamment est
la possible fermeture des écoles mais
pour l'instant ce n'est qu'une hypothèse
et pour espérer vacciner 30 millions on
s'est dit si elles étaient au moins 35
vaccinodromes vont être ouverts en
france après avoir longuement réunis et
à mettre en place ces méga centres de
vaccination le gouvernement a changé
d'avis cette semaine un changement de
doctrine tarifs qui questionne on fait
le point avec théo combes vacciner
vacciner et encore vaccinés
voilà le leitmotiv des manuels macron
alors que les critiques sur la stratégie
vaccinale du gouvernement se multiplient
accompagné par le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand le chef de l'état en
déplacement à valenciennes a tenu à
mettre en scène sa détermination
maintenant le coeur de la bataille sur
les prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois ce sera la vaccination
matin midi et soir je peux vous dire je
serai mobiliser le gouvernement sera
mobilisé et l'ensemble je le sais des
professionnels soignants partout en
france sera mobilisée dans cette
bataille
la vaccination est une priorité
nationale il n'y a pas de jours fériés
il n'y a pas de week-end pour la
vaccination est donc nous devons dans
tous les centres de vaccination qui sont
ouverts sur le sol national vaccine est
au maximum pour mettre en oeuvre ses
annonces
le gouvernement a décidé de changer de
braquet l'option des vaccinodromes
encore écartée il y a quelques mois
pourrait devenir le bras armé de la
vaccination en france
au moins 35 pourrait apparaître dans les
prochains jours comme par exemple au
stade de france le 6 avril prochain un
revirement de situation qui peut sembler
tardif au vu de leur emploi déjà massif
en allemagne en israël ou encore aux
états unis je pense que tout ça est lié
au traumatisme qu'ont eu les dirigeants
français avec quelques fiascos récent
matière de vaccination
la campagne pour le h1n1 avait été
orchestrée avec force et n'avait pas du
tout rencontrer les français puisque
seulement 10% d'entre eux s'étaient fait
vacciner
il y a eu aussi le scandale de la
vaccination contre l'hépatite b qui en
fait n'en était pas un et qui s'est
dégonflé tout cela probablement un peu
traumatisé les dirigeants si aucune date
précise n'a encore été évoquée pour
l'ouverture d'autres vaccinodromes
l'armée et les pompiers feront partie du
dispositif
ces méga centres seraient ouverts sept
jours sur sept afin de démultiplier les
possibilités de se faire vacciner
une campagne de vaccination aux allures
industrielle qui pose la question de son
approvisionnement
car si le pays est en guerre contre le
virus comme l'a annoncé emmanuel macron
en mars 2020 la gagner sera beaucoup
plus difficile sans munitions et pour en
parler nous sommes avec christian à
châtel mer les centristes de janvry dans
l'essonne bonsoir escient schatten merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
les vaccinodromes alors on doit dire les
un centre à tension c'est la nouvelle
solution c'est forcément la solution
parce qu'il faut aller très vite
maintenant
ce qui est consternant c'est que on nous
avait dit que ça servait à rien ce qui
est consternant
je veux dire pour moi ce qui est plus
grave que le virus c'est la perte de
confiance de l'opinion publique et de
nos concitoyens dans la parole publique
le jour où on aura perdu la confiance
c'est que la parole de l'état ne sera
sera plus valable
eh bien ils obéiront plus à rien ils
respecteront plus rien et quelque part
le spectacle qu'on leur donne depuis
quelque temps le justifie pleinement
alors c'est vrai que c'est une
changement de doctrine d'un de plus dans
toute cette stratégie anti qu'ovide ça
vous évoque quoi du pragmatisme ou au
contraire de la confusion
moi je trouve que c'est extrêmement
dommage qu'on soit pas honnête avec le
citoyen nous ne les français sont pas
idiots on peut leur dire on n'a pas
assez de vaccins pour faire des
vaccinodromes quand on aura des vaccins
au phrasé vaccinodromes et avouer qu'on
n'a pas assez de vaccins
c'est comme avouer qu'on n'a pas assez
de masques donc on a l'impression qu'on
va être pilonné et du coup on se réfugie
derrière des mensonges et le public
n'étant pas idiot il s'en rend compte et
donc là on est dans des actes et renoir
mans qui on va avoir la même chose sur
les enfants quittant l'entente sont
porteurs de virus d'antan et ne sont pas
suivant ce que ça arrange
c'est consternant parce que il faut
fondamentalement que nos habitants nous
fassent confiance que quand l'ordi
choses soient sûrs que c'est la vérité
aujourd'hui on leur ment par peur de la
judiciarisation de toute cette affaire
ça veut dire concrètement que les gens
vont se rendre dans des vaccinodromes
comme le stade de france par exemple et
que ça va être
vide où on ne va pas trouver de deux
vaccins comment les choses vont se
passer concrètement ça pose de sacrés
problèmes logistiques
non moi je pense que là on est parti sur
des volumes de vaccins qui nous arrive
qu'ils vont permettre de le faire
on a pris trois semaines de retard par
rapport à tout le monde et moi je vois
parmi mes habitants tout le monde veut
se faire vacciner
on peut regretter qu'on soit à dire
maintenant c'est moins de soixante dix
ans je pense que évidemment les
enseignants devraient être vaccinés très
très vite n'est pas que les enseignants
les gens qui sont dans les cantines et
s'occupe des gosses etc tous ces gens là
sont prioritaires à re devront attendre
la mi avril c'est mieux vaut tard que
jamais où il aurait fallu les faire
passer encore avant l'écouté madame si
on va dans l'est dans les centres de
vaccination s'aperçoit que de la place
franchement ces coupes crétins il faut y
aller et il faut boucher tous les trous
on sait bien aujourd'hui en angleterre
on a seize morts par jour pendant que
nous on les cumuls par centaines
juste il faut aller très vite le plus
vite possible et pas commencer à faire
des dosages des quotas ça me paraît
curieux quoi j'ai à ces gens là sont
normalement intelligents et ils nous on
n'est que des petits élus locaux
justement à propos d' élus locaux on a
entendu beaucoup de vos collègues se
plaindre voilà de ces centres qui vont
être mis en place qui vont donner un
coup à la proximité dont parfois
certaines populations beaucoup besoin
notamment le je pense aux personnes
âgées ça va être compliqué pour eux
c'est sûr je sais que aujourd'hui dans
nos petits centres de vaccination il
faut qu'on organise des transports jan
et à côté humain de le convaincre
quelqu'un d'y aller de l'emmener en
voiture et c'est que c'est vrai que
c'est ces grandes usines à gaz peut
faire peur et à mon avis à la place pour
les deux et à ma connaissance nous
n'avons pas des manques de vaccin du
fait de la création des vaccinodromes et
que c'est évidemment la vaccination
de masse qui peut nous permettre que à
partir du 14 juillet immunité soit
atteinte en europe on oublie également
puisqu'on parle de proximité la
vaccination des médecins des pharmaciens
c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à à à suivre
cette stratégie mais je pense que à la
fois on a eu droit aux épisodes où
c'était forcément le comité scientifique
qui donnait toutes les leçons du monde
après ça ça a été on n'a plus voulu en
entendre parler
c'est vrai qu'on est dans des stop and
go sur l'ensemble des décisions alors
qu'il faut juste que je connais rien
encore une pomme avec beaucoup de
modestie mais on a l'impression que le
conscience tous les gens qui sont en
contact y'a pas que les médecins il ya
même les commerçants de bouche qui sont
là tous les jours à servir des gens
ces gens là ils devraient en priorité il
faut y aller
et comme comme on a du stock c'est ça me
paraît quand même très très bizarre très
bizarre
christophe mazel vous êtes pro chaude de
vos administrés comment vont-ils
aujourd'hui parce que c'est vrai qu'on
entend qu'il ya de plus en plus de
résignation de déprime et que finalement
les gens n'ont pas si peur que ça du
virus j'entendais tout simplement
médecin me l'a raconté ce matin médecin
qui reçoit l'as des patients toutes les
demi heures nous disent voilà ils sont
tellement résigné il ya même plus est
cette peur qui fait qu'on adhère au aux
restrictions c'est inquiétant alors moi
je vais vous faire une confession moi
sur ma commune je vends le témoin qui
vend le pas en porte à porte pour éviter
aux gens d'aller dans les boulangeries
donc je prends ma voiture et je fais
tous les matins à tourner de pain c'est
vrai que les gens n'y comprennent plus
rien histoire de l'attestation qu'il
avait besoin de besoin il ya un moment
où la crédibilité public ce que je
disais tout à l'heure aux problèmes
et comme il n'ya pas de crédibilité
c'est vrai qu'il ya des moments où on
sent que ça suffit c'est ces règles
qu'on leur impose n'ont plus de valeur
et donc c'est là où un danger c'est là
où c'est plus dangereux qu locaux vides
en lui-même c'est quand tout d'un coup
nous tirait de républicains peuvent être
balayés et on sent bien
espèce pas ras-le-bol général qui fait
que y'a pas que les règles de porter les
masques ou des 10 km tout est en train
d'en être embarqué par un tsunami de
ras-le-bol
merci en tout cas de votre témoignage
christian à certaines mères les
centristes de janvry dans l'essonne
merci d'avoir été avec nous et encore
une polémique visant feu l'application
stop kobe de l'association anticor a
déposé une plainte à la cour de justice
contre olivier véran motifs l'absence de
règles d'attribution des marchés publics
concernant les contrats liés à cette
application
y aurait-il eu favoritisme les
explications de katia technique
l'application française stop qu'ovide
enterré depuis le 22 octobre 2020 refait
parler d'elle
on se souvient des polémiques liées à ce
top cow vide au sujet des données
personnelles puis de sa technologie puis
de son faible taux de téléchargement et
aujourd'hui c'est au tour de
l'association anticor d'agiter
l'épouvantail
l'organisation anticorruption a porté
plainte en janvier contre le ministre de
la santé olivier ferrand selon anticor
les contrats de gestion de l'application
n'ont été soumis à aucune procédure de
passation de marchés publics
l'association rappelle dans sa plainte
que le code de la commande publique
exige cette procédure pour les contrats
supérieurs à cent trente neuf mille
euros hors taxes on se souvient encore
que le 27 mai 2020 cedrico le secrétaire
d'état au numérique s'était targuée
d'avoir développé l'application grâce au
concours d'agent ce public et de start
up
intervenant à titre gracieux la
participation des entreprises privées au
développement a été gratuit je m'en
félicite l'entreprise l'une habits dont
on parle dans les médias qui est à
chambéry je crois que ces 15 personnes
pendant plusieurs semaines sept de ces
développeurs ont travaillé gratuitement
pour aider l'état à développer une
application sanitaires je veux les
remercier
tout comme je vais remercier tous les
grands groupes toutes les autres
certains qui ont travaillé sur le sujet
quelle fin négociateur
mais en réalité dès le démarrage de
l'application de contacts racing en juin
les entreprises ont logiquement commencé
à être rémunéré et la douloureuse a
atteint un montant compris entre 200
milles et 300000 euros par mois
régler à capgemini la start-up l'une à
bille ou encore out skies une filiale de
dassault systèmes qui assure
l'hébergement
la maintenance 40000 euros mensuels pour
l'hébergement informatique 40000 à 80000
euros par mois pour la maintenance et le
développement
cinquante mille euros par mois d'appui
au support utilisateur trente mille
euros par mois pour les frais de
déploiement
ce à quoi il faut ajouter près de 3
millions d'euros de campagne de
communication l'attribution de tous ces
marchés a attiré l'attention d'anticorps
qui porte donc plainte
chacun des postes de dépenses qu'il
s'agisse de la communication ou de
l'exploitation de l'application aurait
dû faire l'objet d'un appel d'offres ou
d'une procédure de mise en concurrence
au regard de leur montant
sans même tranchée sur un éventuel
favoritisme ces montants élevés seraient
moins polémique six top cow vide avait
été un succès stop coville n'a été
téléchargé que 2,5 millions de fois
désinstaller un million de fois et
réinstaller 300 mille fois le rapport de
la commission d' enquête sur la gestion
gouvernementale de l'épidémie rendu en
décembre 2020 a étrillé le bilan de ce
top cow vide
l'état a dépensé 6,5 millions d'euros
pour 5553 test positif scanner dans
l'application 346 alerte dont 296
effectivement transmises ça fait cher
l'alertent presque 22000 euros
mais il existe une raison de se réjouir
tel le phénix stop qu'ovide a pu
renaître de ses cendres en octobre en
version améliorée plus précises et
complètes sous le nom de tous antico
vide et cette fois-ci les français l'ont
téléchargée 13,9 millions de fois et
l'apli a émis son 1000 alerte c'est bien
mieux
alors voyons ce qu'en pensent les
internautes dans les avis suite à la
dernière mise à jour l'application ne
fonctionne plus à chaque lancement j'ai
le message
impossible d'initialiser antico vide
j'ai été testée positive le 19 mars j'ai
rentrer le code pour me signaler dans
l'après midi même et nous sommes le 21
et mon mari qui vit avec moi n'a
toujours pas eu d' alerte
ça lui dit toujours pas de contacts à
risque détecté l'appli est bien mes
plantes est donc obligé de désinstaller
réinstaller mais les attestations
dérogatoire ne sont toujours pas à jour
ce n'est pas encore ça mais croisons les
doigts l'application sera peut être
irréprochable lors de la troisième vague
près la stratégie d' emmanuel macron
pour faire face à la crise sanitaire
mise à mal donc face à la propagation du
barnier aux britanniques et parler
nombreux retards de livraison de vaccins
l'exécutif est il en train de perdre le
contrôle de l'épidémie et d'une autre
échéance cette fois-ci électorale avec
les régionales un report n'est pas à
exclure c'est l'objet de notre édito
aujourd'hui avec alexis paul un bon soir
alexis poulain merci d'être avec nous en
retard et couacs à répétition on en
parle depuis le début de cette émission
communication désastreuse
emmanuel macron se met-il en danger dans
sa gestion très incarnée de la crise
sanitaire
oui clairement il a choisi cette voie
étroite 1 il n'a pas voulu re confiné
quand les autres partenaires européens
confus mais parce qu'il prenait au
sérieux le variant anglais et que dès
décembre il savait que 6e varions
commencé à commencent à arriver sur les
territoires et bien ce serait très
difficile de gérer mal à croire dit non
nous attendrons nous verrons on est
toujours dans la tente avec beaucoup de
semaines de retard
nous ne faisons pas de séquençage très
peu de traçage l'application stop
qu'ovide est un fiasco et la gestion
également incarné par mâcon comme vous
le dites est un fiasco mais pas
seulement avec lui regardez le cas
astrazeneca la vaccination qui
commençait à peine s'arrête parce
qu'effectivement ce vaccin poserait
question et des questions il y en a avec
ses thrombose veineuse rares qui ont tué
des personnes jeunes qui ont reçu le
vaccin et aujourd'hui on voit bien que
la défiance est revenu que les gens
rechignent à accepter cette vaccination
avec astrazeneca et puis il y à l'omerta
des dirigeants européens qui se refuse à
dire que la commission européenne a été
un fiasco
dans cette centrale d'achat des vaccins
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui la pénurie est
partout en europe
également en allemagne ou dans d'autres
pays
donc on est là dans un moment terrible
de d'une fin d'un système où à la fois
les dirigeants nationaux mais les
dirigeants européens
aveuglé par une certaine idéologie qui
leur empêche un de commander des vaccins
par exemple le spoutnik des à la russie
on voit attendre avril avant de voir ce
qu'il va se passer
le vaccin chinois également eh bien nous
sommes en europe dans une pénurie totale
les médecins les syndicats de médecins
urgentistes le disent et d'autre
emmanuel macron lui a choisi pire encore
d'être celui qui est l épidémiologiste
en chef celui qui dessinaient tout en
conseil de défense exceptionnelle
lui qui donne les arbitrages finaux et
c'est lui qui pique des colères noires
comme un mauvais manager qui accuse les
rangs subalternes de faire n'importe
quoi alors que les rangs subalternes ne
font qu'obéir aux ordres du patron et
c'est lui le patron
donc je pense que oui effectivement
cette gestion enfantine irritante et
totalement immature de la crise va lui
coûter très cher et nous coûtent
également très cher parce que on ne
parie pas avec la vie des français comme
il l'a fait il sortie de crise
imaginez bien il ya deux scénarios
possibles et il ya le scénario optimiste
où le sérieux ou pessimiste voire
tragiques alors on va commencer par le
pire le scénario tragique
imaginons que le vaccin fonctionne qu'on
reçoive suffisamment de doses et qu'on
est les 30 millions de vaccinés avant
l'été que me promis par le premier
ministre jean castex alors on serait
vers le retour à la normale et puis le
déconfinement arriverait seulement là
arrive le problème de la dette la dette
kovy d'un ce plan de relance qui est
finalement un plan de soutien à une
économie à l'arrêt parce qu'il ya une
mauvaise gestion sanitaire est là que se
passe-t-il et bien ce serait des
faillites en chaîne qui auraient été
simplement retarder un chômage de masse
rendu encore plus délicat par la réforme
de l'assurance chômage qui continue même
si elle isabelle borne est à l'hôpital
la réforme de l'assurance-chômage indien
est revenu sur la table en disant nous
devons continuer cette réforme
donc on serait avec davantage de
français sous le seuil de la pauvreté
c'est déjà un français sur six qui est
sous le seuil de la pauvreté cette année
ça pour être davantage
compte tenu de cette gestion calamiteuse
de la crise alors ça c'est le pire mais
il se pourrait que l'on choisirait quand
même un plan de relance économique en
soutenant la consommation
ça ce serait éventuellement à un moyen
d'aider les entreprises qui retrouverait
un peu d'air avec des français qui
consomment
mais ce n'est pas le choix qui est fait
par les écuries faut aujourd'hui non le
choix est à la fois de faire de
l'austérité et de faire du ruissellement
à cette stratégie qui ne fonctionne pas
en donnant de l'argent à ceux qui en ont
c'est à dire soutenir les banques les
investisseurs en pensant que vont créer
de l'emploi et eux vont permettre de
soutenir l'économie
là c'est tout faire pour empêcher le
rebond économique pourtant appelée de
ses voeux par errer bruno le maire le
ministre de l'économie et là ça pourrait
être une catastrophe avec non seulement
une crise sanitaire mais en plus le en
même temps un des manuels ma chronique
économique est là pour 2022 évidemment
ce serait impossible pour répondre de
défendre son bilan
le scénario optimiste ce serait que les
vaccins arrivent fonctionne soit
suffisamment nombreux que la reprise
reprennent comme annoncé par bruno le
maire à 6 % 1 même si c'est un voeu
pieux avant le deuxième semestre
donc c'est loin on serait après l'été
dans tous les cas le bilan sanitaire lui
est catastrophique
80 % de hausse de consultation
psychologique pour les moins de 15 ans
de nombreux suicides j'attends d'avoir
les chiffres sur la vague de suicides
l'épidémie de suicides qui arrivent en
france des dépressions massif chez les
salariés et puis le bilan quand même de
nombreuses pertes d'emplois parce que
les entreprises ne peuvent pas planifié
nous n'avons toujours pas de date de
réouverture pour de nombreux secteurs
qui ont fermé à cause de cette crise
sanitaire
vous avez évoqué la présidentielle de
2000 2022 est ce qu emmanuel macron peut
perdre tous et paris y compris cette
présidentielle à la défaveur de
l'épidémie oui clairement
mais la cour est joueur on l'a vu c'est
comme ça qu'il a gagné d'ailleurs en
2010 est aidé par certains médias qui en
ont fait un champion démocratique
inconnu
aujourd'hui on voit que c'est paris
n'ont été que une succession d'échecs ou
de dangereux paris effectivement qui
n'ont pas réussi à rendre le pays
meilleur ou plus agréable ou même sur
pour de nombreux français il y a ajouté
à la crise sanitaire
une crise sécuritaire terrible peu
importe les gesticulations de gérald
darmanin à l'intérieur on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui la france craint beaucoup
au niveau sécuritaire comme au niveau
sanitaire
donc on voit bien que échec sur échec
mails macro n'a pas réussi à convaincre
n'a pas réussi à montrer qu'ils étaient
ceux dirigeants de start up nation
capable de lancer la france sur les
rails de la modernité et jean castex le
premier ministre choisi pour être le
nouveau paratonnerre après edouard
philippe
et bien ce paratonnerre est épuisé il ne
fonctionne plus la cote de popularité du
président est au même niveau que celui
du premier ministre que celle pardon du
premier ministre tous deux ont la
défiance des français à plus de 60 70 %
dans cette gestion de crise donc c'est
une bérézina total je ne vois pas
comment emmanuel macron pourrait se
représenter avec un tel bilan
sanitaire économique il y a bien bien
sûr un jeune une solution qui est un
plan pour sorte d'aider les jeunes à
entrer sur le marché du travail
sinistrés mais je ne pense pas qu'il
sera suffisant il ya aussi cette volonté
idéologique de continuer avec la dette
sociale française et de faire que cette
dette soit partagé par les plus pauvres
de ne pas faire payer les plus riches
alors qu'eux-mêmes joe biden est né aux
états unis lui va faire payer les
entreprises qui font beaucoup de profits
et les citoyens américains les plus
riches et plus fortunés ce n'est pas là
encore une fois le choix des manuels
mâcon dont je ne vois pas comment lui
pourra faire barrage comme il le
souhaiterait en 2022
face à marine le pen aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment prématuré de parler de la sorte
et on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs toute la stratégie de
l'exécutif des mêmes macron c'est de
séduire une partie de l'électorat des
républicains et même des élus des
républicains les faire venir et
finalement dissoudre la république en
marche pour en faire un autre parti avec
cette partie de la droite qui pourrait
l'aider à surnager dans cette gestion
calamiteuse
alexis avant 2022 il y à d'autres
échéances électorales des régionales
notamment et la république en marche ne
semble pas en très bonne position région
loin de là on l'a vu d'ailleurs lors des
municipales la république en marche a
fait 2 2 % des votes donc c'est une
gifle électorale cinglante pour les
régionales tous les ténors de la
majorité ont décliné l'offre d'être
candidat dans les grandes régions jean
michel blanquer préfère rester à la tête
du ministère de l'éducation nationale et
gérer les clusters dans les écoles
plutôt que de se présenter pour gagner
une région pour la perdre plus tôt et
d'ailleurs la république en marche est
en train de se diluer comme je le disais
décès d'effacer les logos de la
république en marche sur les papiers de
faire des alliances à droite avec les
républicains mais aussi d'essayer de
garder le modèle même si beaucoup d'élus
centristes préféra l'est par exemple en
région parisienne avec valérie pécresse
et préfèrent aller là où ça va gagner
clairement la république en marche
aujourd'hui est un label qui fait perdre
donc je ne vois pas comment ce serait
possible pour le parti présidentiel
d'avoir un score honnête heureux pour
les régionales ça risque d'être encore
une cinglante défaite qui ne présage
rien de l'eau pour 2022 même si m
se poser en candidats du dépassement
c'est à dire être au dessus des partis
être ce président qui a été courageux
dans la crise finalement dont je crois
qu'il a été
irritant dans la crise il a été mauvais
dans la crise son premier ministre
également et cela sera sanctionné dans
les urnes il en est conscient c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça je crois qu'il a
repris le contact avec edouard philippe
le maire du havre qui était son ancien
premier ministre et qui serait une sorte
de plan b resté fidèle jusqu'au bout
pour reprendre le flambeau d'un ni
droite ni gauche en 2022 quand la
candidature des malaises mâcon sera
impossible compte tenu de son bilan
merci alexis pour l'instant élise sur rt
france reste avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de cette
polémique à strasbourg en alsace la
majorité municipale europe ecologie les
verts de la ville a adopté ce lundi le
principe d'une subvention de plus de
deux millions et demi d'euros pour la
construction d'une mosquée un projet
chapeauté par l'association milli gorus
réputé proche de la turquie est critiqué
par le ministre de l'intérieur
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
21h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france polémique à strasbourg en alsace
la majorité municipale europe ecologie
les verts de la ville adopté ce lundi le
principe d'une subvention de plus de
deux millions et demi d'euros pour la
construction d'une mosquée un projet
chapeauté par l'association milite au
russe réputé proche de la turquie est
critiqué par le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin les explications en
images avec france pâtissier beach
adoptée par 42 voix contre 7 en conseil
municipal la délibération approuve le
principe d'une subvention de 2,5 163
millions d'euros pour la construction
d'une mosquée la plus grande d'europe
dans le quartier de la meinau un
chantier évalué à 25 millions d'euros
portée depuis de nombreuses années par
la confédération islamique milli gorus
cette association réputée proche de la
turquie a refusé de signer en janvier
dernier la charte des principes pour
l'islam de france
un texte promu par emmanuel macron dans
sa lutte contre le séparatisme
réaffirmant la compatibilité de la foi
musulmane avec la république et c'est
justement ce refus qui pose problème à
l'opposition municipale et au ministre
de l'intérieur gérald darmanin la mairie
verte de strasbourg finance une mosquée
est soutenue par une fédération qui a
refusé de signer la charte des principes
de l'islam de france et qui défend un
islam politique
vivement que tout le monde ouvre les
yeux et que la loi séparatisme soit
bientôt votée et promulguée mais alors
pourquoi la majorité eux élevé de
strasbourg soutien tels financièrement
ce projet de mosquée en dépit de la loi
de séparation des églises et de l'état
c'est en réalité une spécificité de
l'alsace-moselle car en réalité la loi
de 1905 ne s'applique pas sur l'ensemble
du territoire français
c'est une position qui date de 1999
lorsque le droit local issu du
concordera a été étendue à toutes les
religions autorisée par l'état
il y à une délibération cadre qui
prévoit un dispositif de subvention
automatique de tous les lieux de culte 9
à hauteur de 10% du coût du projet 2,5
millions d'euros
ce n'est pas une paille et ça ne fait
pas que du bien à notre budget mais vous
imaginez qu'on change la règle
maintenant juste au moment où c'est une
association musulmane qui demande une
subvention
ça serait au mieux maladroit et
certainement très mal perçu le versement
de la subvention doit encore faire
l'objet d'un nouveau vote
démarrée en 2017 le chantier de la
mosquée a dû faire face à des problèmes
de financement
il est actuellement à l'arrêt alors la
mairie de strasbourg n'aurait-elle pas
dû financer une mosquée est soutenue par
une fédération qui a refusé signé la
charte des principes de l'islam et qui
défend un islam politique comme le dit
virginie genre ont débuté reine soleil
qui vote il a financé les islamistes
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec gamal à bina cofondateur du
mouvement des droits civiques bonsoir
gamma d'amina merci d'être avec nous fin
aux ja gariel à vos côtés secrétaire
national de la république souveraine
pour la laïcité bonsoir madame merci
d'être avec nous on a entendu donc le
ministre d'intérieur pas content du tout
voilà qui rappelle que cette fédération
a refusé de signer la charte des
principes de l'islam et une clos sa
critique en disant vivement que tout le
monde ouvre les yeux et que la loi
séparatistes ne soient bientôt votée et
promulguée gamal el abida avec cette
fois séparatisme ça n'aurait pas été
possible la construction de cette
mosquée je jure l'offensive aujourd'hui
qu'on observe la question de l'islam de
france
évidemment s'il part d'une loi qui n'est
pas encore votée selon a pas été
possible parce que c'est tout est très
restrictive mais mais a contrario
l'alsace-moselle texte l'excellent the
lorraine est un territoire allemand on a
peu près 50 ans et cette spécificité
régionale a autorisé financement des
cultes des quatre cultes
le clip qui sera élite le réformés
calvinistes donc le problème c'est que
on veut interdire à un culte bénéficient
de cette spéciale dans une région c'est
que les autres droit d'avoir ce qui est
pas normal alors c'est vrai qu'on va
parler du son aussi du débat parce qu'il
ya eu d'autres critiques mais faouzia
gariel effectivement la loi sur le
concordat autorise ce type de deux
subventions en alsace que ça plaise ou
non est ce que vous vous trouvez cela
choquant oui dans la mesure où ce n'est
pas la construction de la mosquée et la
subvention qui lui est accordée qui ils
sont c'est plutôt le fait que c'est
monstre qu'est comme bien d'autres
mosquées d'ailleurs en france soit sous
le contrôle du millet goris le milieu
russe qui est une organisation islamique
islamique sous le contrôle de la diyanet
oms et le ministère des cultes en
turquie et contrôle des
de la capter don kelly au service d'un
soft power
erdogan bien d'accord pour étendre son
influence sont toutes les communautés
musulmanes de france en prônant en
soutenant un islam conservateur
patriarcale
il le met ligori qui siège d'ailleurs ou
qui est membre statutaire du conseil
français du culte musulman a refusé de
signer la charte proposée donc par le
président emmanuel macron pour les
principes donc de 10 thèmes de france et
pour cause ils ne sont pas d'accord avec
la laïcité
ils sont favorables à ce que les saints
porte une burqa dont un voile peu
importe que les femmes n'occupent pas
certains métiers et il se sent la
turquie s'est retirée donc de là la
charte du conseil de l'europe de la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes qu'ils avaient signé en 2011
au prétexte que ces chartes finalement
sur la cohésion familiale quoi donc on
finance effectivement une mosquée sous
contrôle d'une organisation islamique
l'islam politique louis légaux russe ne
s'en cache pas il le dit lui même très
proche donc des frères musulmans et
notamment de tariq ramadan qui sont
porteurs d'un projet politique
voilà gamal financement c'est mon la wii
a beaucoup de mélanges d'abord ses
lectures que c'est patrick ramade or
vous mélangez le fromage une monture
égyptien ça n'a rien à voir
ensuite et surtout vous avez des
références il me dit madame je vous
discipline donc je vous disais donc
ensuite burqa et voile c'est pas la même
chose fort a été trouvé lors j'ai leur
casser afghans dans un pays qui sort de
ce en temps de guerre
donc ça pays qui a beaucoup de problèmes
à résoudre en interne et la burqa ne
s'exporte pas ensuite concernant le
financement des cultes
oui il faut financer hicules pour sortir
du financement extérieur est propre et
les musulmans de france ne sont pas
tenues par les sionistes et 10 passes
culture sur le très minoritaires les
musulmans puissent autonomie c'est quand
une mère écologistes à l'intelligence
d'appliquer les lois de la région alsace
moselle donc je ne vois pas comment ai
je ne vois pas pourquoi
mocratie la démocratie l'appui direct
qui s'appelle la municipalité vote un
texte à une écrasante majorité est le
premier ministre qui n'est plus dans son
rôle intervient il ya quelque chose qui
ne va pas ensuite il n'y a pas de lois
rétroactives en france c'est un pays de
droit si les lois n'existent pas les
applique pas à s'exhiber existe à ce
moment là on discute aujourd'hui il ya
un vrai problème en terme de six pages
et concernant le mélange des deux si
c'est pour finir le mélange des genres
je le deviens confère le féminisme le
droit des femmes soyez pas trop mal je
souscris mais là on parle de
construction de mosquées gens priaient
on parle pas de dix hommes politiques
toutes les mosquées de france sont sous
contrôle et un français les services
d'enseignement font leur travail
ce mic d'un état extérieur qui
viendraient et la cinquième colonne
fabriqué par l'extrême droite
vous savez ce qui s'est passé on va
donner évidemment la parole fawzi à
gariane je voudrais vous proposer
justement avant d'écouter la mer fameuse
maire écologiste de strasbourg qui nous
parle justement de valeurs de la
république parce que c'est de cela que
faouzia gariel parlais tout à l'heure
c'est peut-être ça qui pose problème
pour certains écoutent et la mer
j'entends que gérald darmanin pose un
certain nombre de questions est ce que
du coup ça signifie qu'ils s'opposent
qui remet en cause le droit local et et
le concordat dans ce cas là je pense
qu'il faut le dire clairement est-ce que
du coup c'est une manière de dire que le
gouvernement souhaite mettre en cause le
concordat et les règles en vigueur dans
notre dans notre région dans ce cas là
je pense qu'il faut il faut le dire
clairement
et si par contre il a des doutes ou des
alertes par particulière concernant le
respect des valeurs de la république
c'est aussi à lui de le dire pour ma
part j'ai fait confiance et aux
responsables locaux antérieur et aux
services de l'état avec lesquels
j'entretiens un dialogue constant sur un
certain nombre de sujets alors
manifestement ministre de l'intérieur a
plutôt une dent contrôle à la deuxième
partie un les valeurs de la république
que vous dénoncez également vous aussi
fazia gariel mais ça veut dire quoi
selon vous avec ce que vous nous avez
dit twitter que les services de l'état
un état laïc je le rappelle malgré tout
n'ont pas bien fait leur travail à
madame je ne pense pas je pense que je
pense que le milieu russe est une
organisation qui est très très bien
structuré qui donne des gages et qui qui
peut se montrer extrêmement coopérante
respectueux sur le moment mais en fait
il ya quand même un travail de fond qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui par exemple vous
donne un exemple l'organisation au sein
du cfcm
la branche marocaine s'est rallié à
l'islam turc d'islam conservateur sous
l'influencé justement de cette
organisation du mailing aux russes fois
c'est un disque âme quand même qu'ils
aient ces dix simples conservateur est à
l'islam qui est contre les républiques
et notamment la laïcité et l'égalité
hommes-femmes quoi évidemment ce n'est
pas la construction des mosquées qu'on
critique loin de stade louis ii
2 les musulmans en droit d'avoir des
lieux de culte question n'est pas là
c'est que ces mosquées là sous contrôle
du mil diego russe ils sont
indirectement ce contrôle de la cap et
qui les utilisent comme un soft power
pour étendre son influence en europe sur
les communautés de communes de lecture
les communautés musulmanes gamme alabina
faudrait devant oui parce que ça fait un
peu désordre dans ce contexte que vous
savez évidemment tendue sur ce sujet
voilà prendre précisément la fédération
qui refusent de signer cette charte sur
la laïcité c'est un petit peu ça fait
désordre non sur l'islam de france par
nos parce que non parce que ça pose
problème pas seulement à cette
aberration c'est inquiète les
protestants s'est inquiété les juifs si
l'on vous parlait il ya beaucoup de
groupes organisés qui disent quand on
commence à faire des lois si blanc
on appelle ça les lois d'exception
partir du moment où on fait ce genre de
loi ça rappelle des vieilles lois dans
les années 40 et le problème aujourd'hui
c'est que on parle de financement ça
pose problème on nous mélange les genres
on dit voilà on aurait payé laïque donc
le droit des femmes la laïcité c'est pas
le droit des femmes le droit des femmes
c'est dans la constitution française la
laïcité c'est la séparation des églises
et de l'état
elle est appliquée elle ne peut pas être
réformé de ce point de vue là parce que
ça fait longtemps qu'il est appliqué en
revanche quand on voit des musulmans
s'organise et se structurer
immédiatement c'est le coup du de la
tête de turc réalisons en lecture
commence à bien dieu pardonne
je vais faire de mauvais jeu de mots
mais megan à la vie non je ne fais pas à
côté voilà cette fédération qui est
remise en cause par ce qu'elle refuse de
signer voilà la charte des principes de
l'islam de france entend bien voilà
c'est pas la seule prennent pas là c'est
que si elle ne les signe pas à dire le
maire l'a précisé
elle doit signer pour avoir la
subvention la règle mais ce qui se passe
c'est que cette génération d'arrêter le
chantier parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
d'argent donc l'organisation et le soft
power
on se demande où il est ensuite et
surtout parce qu'on a le sentiment qu'à
chaque fois qu'on parle de la communauté
arabo musulmane ou turcot musulmane ça
devient un problème au lieu de créer des
ponts au crédit ont créé des faux c est
pourquoi les autres et pour très bientôt
dans les sortir que les verts le parti
des verts fort allié ou non vers
musulmans à force de caricature on
arrive à ça moi je suis pour la loi mais
pas la loi qui n'existe pas et en aucun
cas une loi qui est imposé par ministre
l'intérieur qui est en campagne
la question est de savoir faouzia gariel
cette fois sur le concordat
quel exemple le fait de jeter un oeil
clairement sur les principes de la
république
oui ou non non elle n'exempte pas du
tout la loi sur le concours donne des
deux n'est pas synonyme de deux je
dirais d'autonomie de séparatisme
vis-à-vis donc des principes de la
république
toutes les organisations culturelles
doivent pratiquer dans république et en
particulier la laïcité on part aussi
l'égalité hommes-femmes même si ça ne
rentre pas dans le cadre de la laïcité
c'est quand même le bigot russe oeuvre
pour l'expansion d'un mystère je répète
très conservateur très patriarcales et
ce n'est pas conforme aux principes donc
nous la république c'est tout oc & c est
ce ce n'était pas moi qui les
remplissent et dans la charte dans la
charte en la charte du mil d'ego russe
qui se dit lui-même proche des frères
musulmans lancé que les frères musulmans
sont porteurs d'un projet politique
gaba la vida on en n'est pas notre
premier scandale à en alsace puisque
mulhouse accueille le centre à nous
aura d'ailleurs nos confrères à
christian chesnot et georges malbrunot
écrit un livre sur le sujet cat 1 et
nice par ce jeu des sites ce sont deux
journées liste voilà on est de leur bord
ou pas il travaille au figaro mais enfin
pour eux c'est une manière d'en racines
et développer l'islam politique en
europe dans des mosquées qui sont les
centres de vie voilà financé par une ong
qatari est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec cette analyse c'est encore une
forme de sorte de chasse aux sorcières
pour vous le problème c'est que l'islam
politique au france n'existe pas moi
c'était rigolo qu'on me donne le pouvoir
de l'islam politique
ils sont incapables d'organiser des
élections de porter quelqu'un pouvoir
ils sont incapables de financer jusqu'au
bout ils font des levées de fonds qui
durent des années ils n'ont pas le
soutien des états d'origine on parle
d'islam consulaire
étrangement il est pas présent et on
parle toujours des frères musulmans
comme si c'était un poids prépondérant
en france il n'existe pas alors si vous
n'y a pas de montrer une organisation
politique qui va aux élections et il est
passé 10 % à ce moment là je vous dirais
qu'il avait raison mais ce n'est pas le
cas ensuite concernant les droits des
femmes ce qu'on parle beaucoup de ça on
l'associé jolie âmes droits des femmes
le pays le plus rétrograde au monde en
matière de droit des femmes c'est
l'arabie et bizarrement il n'y a pas
trop de mon les critiques jamais ce qui
est étonnant ce soft power de l'arabie
qui achètent beaucoup de choses n'ai
jamais critiqué
moi j'aimerais qu'on ait la même
attitude vis à vis de l'arabie qui est
pas mal de la france sauf et la turquie
qui n'est plus allée depuis 20 ans
arrive au pouvoir et on l'entendra ça
aussi se situe jamais 2 si jamais le
parti tient la porte on notera celle de
avec tous les partis ils m'ont pas de
plus en plus entendre de collusion le
régime d'origine que le problème
lebel son contrôle moi je vous le dis
parce que je suis tant il faut enfin
j'ai gagné
le mot de la fin l'islam politique
n'existe pas en france comme nous
l'affirmons gamme alabina au nombre
écouter on peut toujours voir les choses
comme ça amélie c'est un politique
existe parfaitement émile-legault russe
c'est l'organisation
je dirais même nos structures et qui
bénéficie de financements de la part d'
angles depuis de son pays d'origine mais
aussi de du qatar
je dois rappeler que à l'origine il veut
demander donc de l'aide ou cas par une
temps qatari ils ne l'ont pas obtenue
ils ont préféré se tourner vers des
financements locaux des financements
donc de la mairie il était pas été prévu
également de demander du financement du
conseil régional à hauteur de 8% et la
communauté européenne impose aussi à
hauteur du pur sang que l'islam
politique n'existe pas ça c'est vraiment
séduit son fils les stars politiques
existent parfaitement en france il y a
un projet qui bien ficelé on le sent on
le connaît il me dit bruce est le
meilleur représentant aujourd'hui de cet
islam en france
merci en tout cas à tous les deux gammes
alabina fin aux a gagné elle d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur ert france
d'avoir exprimé vos points de vue
respectifs
les bureaux de vote seront fermés il y à
quelques instants en israël benyamin
nétanyahou arriverez en première place
selon des sondages de sortie des urnes
mais ils n'obtiendraient pas une
majorité de sièges permettant de former
le nouveau et le prochain gouvernement
israélien et est apte et une nouvelle
fois à voter pour renouveler leur
parlement la knesset pour les quatrièmes
législatives en moins de deux ans lors
des dernières élections aucun des deux
principaux candidats n'a réussi à réunir
une majorité absolue les précisions
depuis tel aviv de paula slayer
journalistes pour rt internationale
beaucoup d'israéliens fou conscience à
benyamin nétanyahou en raison de
il est perçu comme un homme fort en
défenseur pour israël notamment contre
l'iran qui est considéré comme la menace
principale pour israël aujourd'hui il
est également l'ancien ministre des
finances
s'il ya des compétences financières et
beaucoup d'israéliens salue ses
contributions à la solidité de
l'économie
il est connu et respecté à l'étranger ce
qui est important pour les israël
il est vrai que c'est de l'histoire
d'israël le dirigeant qui est resté le
plus longtemps au pouvoir
il est donc normal qu'ils soient connus
sur la scène internationale de plus
benyamin nétanyahou est membre du parti
likoud est dans la société israélienne
si quelqu'un de vote pour le likoud il
est probable que ses enfants et petits
enfants
votre ont également pour le double c'est
vrai pour tous les partis même ceux qui
n'aiment pas forcément benyamin
nétanyahou s'ils soutiennent le lit se
battront pour lui aujourd'hui
enfin je souhaite noter que même si
benyamin nétanyahou ne remporte pas
l'élection
la coalition est lui sera la coalition
la plus à droite de l'histoire d'israël
beaucoup de partis de droite sont en
lice donc la droite va engranger de bons
résultats et pour en parler nous sommes
avec gérard vespière analyse
géopolitique chercheur associé à la
fondation d'études pour le moyen-orient
bonsoir m pierre merci d'être avec nous
quatrièmes élections législatives en
deux ans ça fait beaucoup quand même une
grande instabilité politique qui règne
en israël cette fois ci c'est la
dernière a peut-être peut-être pas le
problème de fond vient effectivement de
la disparition à du parti qui a souvent
gouverné israël ya pendant de nombreuse
dizaine d'années le parti travailliste
qui maintenant ne représente plus que 5
% des sièges donc la disparition de
cette de ce parti qui équilibrait à
entre droite et gauche qui donnait donc
une balance à a produit par son
implosion une grande dispersion des voix
alors il faut savoir que effectivement
dans ce scrutin de liste
vous disposez de sièges à partir du
moment où votre liste a obtenu au moins
3,25 pour cent des sièges des voir nos
trois avec une pause avec 25% des voix
donc directement vous avez par ce
paramétrage du scrutin un grand nombre
de listes et la coalition qui va diriger
le pays ne peut être construite qu'après
le résultat dans les urnes étant donné
le grand émiettement potentiel il n'est
pas possible de construire une coalition
avant le scrutin la fin de la journée le
taux de participation était de 51,20
nulle part dont 51 8 5 % soit 4 8 % en
moins par rapport à l'année dernière est
ce qu'il ya une forme de lassitude de la
part des israéliens alors ça peut être
un facteur mais n'oublions pas non plus
la situation sanitaire a donc qui
n'encourage pas forcément aux
déplacements donc
je crois que quatre scrutins
effectivement en deux ans c'est beaucoup
il n'y a pas d'enjeu non plus à
l'intérieur
n'est ce pas israël pour le moment il
n'y a pas de grands conflits il n'ya
plus d'anti fada il n'ya plat de
cerfs-volants incendiaires voilà un lien
certain apaisement à eau au moins d'être
nature militaire avec le hamas et à avec
la cisjordanie
donc vous avez des anges ou simplement
extérieur et qui sont moins prégnant
dans la situer dans la société
israélienne
il ya tout de même eu un tir de roquette
tout à l'heure en tirer ce soir depuis
gaza en direction d'israël c'est devenu
voilà coutumier évidemment ça ne date
pas d'aujourd'hui mais ça veut dire qu'à
une forme quand même de pression sur ces
élections de tensions ont pas vraiment
comme vous le signe et vous même quand
c'est pas une roquette qui va changer
vraiment le coup road de ce vote
ah s'il y avait effectivement des
dizaines de requêtes et tous les jours
oui là on aurait une situation là ce
n'est pas un événement ce n'est pas une
situation et je crois que le le peuple
israélien dans la conjecture conjoncture
actuelle regarde ce qui se passe autour
de lui et est donc là vous avez des
craintes vis-à-vis du hezbollah libanais
vous avez des craintes avec les actions
de l'iran et est donc la demande d'un
premier ministre fort d'un premier
ministre qui a fait ses preuves et sur
lequel bien tous les dossiers à qui lui
étaient reprochés le dossier 1000 2000
3000 4000 1
concernant des affaires d'influencé ou
davantage qu'il aurait obtenu est bien
ne pèse plus rien maintenant ce sont
vraiment les conditions extérieures qui
ont la primauté est ce que benyamin
netanyahou peut une nouvelle fois
incarner cet homme fort sachant il
affiche un beau succès sur sa campagne
vaccinale un souk au vide
alors oui c'est un homme fort comment
votre présentatrice eu tout à l'heure la
mentionner îlots porte en lui même il a
une force naturelle
donc est ce ce que les israéliens je
lirai accepte bien volontiers ils ont
besoin d'un leader fort et reconnu la
lutte contre le coc vide a été un succès
relativement important donc cela va dans
le bon sens et cela peut l'aider mais il
faut pas oublier que dans le la knesset
dans le parlement qui vient de sortir
n'est ce pas le likoud ne représente que
36 sièges c'est à dire simplement 30%
des voix
donc une des faiblesses de sept de ces
coalitions qui se sont succédé c'est que
le parti le plus fort
le parti leader et bien était simplement
autour des 30% et qu'il devait s'appuyer
sur des alliés qui avec 20 ou 25% de
voix avec plusieurs listes et bien
pesait pratiquement autant que lui
d'espagne il ya une grande différence
politique entre un pari un parti par
donkey à 30% des sièges ou un parti qui
à 45 % des ciel et qui a besoin de
partenaires pour former une majorité
d'ailleurs question en cas de victoire
du likoud justement à quoi doit-on
s'attendre en termes d'alliance
je crois qu'il faut un
il faut attendre parce que comme on
vient de le dire étant donné le nombre
de listes possibles qui peuvent
accompagner le likoud
il n'y a pas de lapin sortir du chapeau
ce soir ah les fameux 3 25% de devoir
qui permettent d'obtenir des sièges donc
sont suffisamment bas et sont même très
bas et donc donne un jeu toujours très
très très ouvert dans les alliances
merci à vous aux gérard respire de nous
avoir apporté votre analyse reste avec
nous dans quelques instants nouveau
point complet sur l'actualité avec
pierre pissavy yvernault quant à moi
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle émission demain à 20h
excellente fin de soirée à tous
[Musique]
comment vous jugez vous la situation
aujourd'hui après plus d'un an de crise
le tourisme est probablement l'une des
filières qui souffrent le plus de la
crise sanitaire le tourisme et
l'événementiel